hey what's up guys my name is eternal
welcome to episode 20 of game
programming so yesterday we took a look
at well actually i game generally
changed yesterday but you know we still
have the same result but what we did do
is actually create this awesome awesome
sprite sheet class which will actually
load a sprite sheet into our into our
project into our to our memory and cache
cache that so that we can actually
access this price within that sprite
sheet so we've we've actually we've got
a way to actually load and again you
know cache that sprite sheet into this
pixel array but how do we actually
access individual sprites now we haven't
actually talked about that yes that's
what that's sort of what we're going to
cover today I'm going to cover like this
bit by bit you know just like a little
bit every day so that you guys can
follow along get get to know the way
that this works really well and you know
I don't really want to rush this I wanna
make sure that you guys understand
everything so um today we're actually
going to cover simply loading a single
sprite ok so what we need to do right
now is actually create a sprite class so
we've got a sprite sheet class and again
that loads our sheet but it doesn't load
individual sprites we want to be able to
load individual sprites so how do we do
that well first of all in the graphics
package chairman it's going to
right-click hit new and then class so
I'm gonna create a new class on the
called sprite
okay I have finished and we want to do
here is find a few variables first of
all we need a size for the sprite so
again same thing as we did in
spreadsheet we got we have this size
here we'll basically do these out same
thing here we'll go private final int
size all right Andrew we won't declare
it yet now again final means it can only
be declared once now it doesn't matter
if you declare it here for example or if
you declare it somewhere else
it can only be declared once and I said
it's final it's constant it's not a
variable will also make - oops private -
private integers called X&Y and I'll
explain all this for in a minute and a
public make sure this is public a public
int
ah actually no I'm they weren't in
public well we'll keep a public for now
but a public int and okay again an array
of integers called pixels
and we won't set that just yet either so
now that we've got this this is like the
basis we actually need one more variable
which I'll talk about in a minute
but I just want to cover this real quick
the size is going to be the size of the
particular sprite now the reason I
haven't defined it straight away here is
because even though our sprite size is
sort of agreed to be 16 right now we
might want to have sprites that are
actually 32 by 32 so in other words
maybe some monsters or something in the
game will actually be larger than tiles
so they'll take up like 2 2 x 2 tiles
instead of 1 by 1 tile so because
obviously that monster or that creature
or whatever will still be a sprite we
sort of want to I want to really use 2
classes for that or whatever we really
don't want redundancy here we want to be
able to just have one Universal sprite
class which we can actually adjust to
suit every sprite in the game now the
other thing is we sort of enabled
ourselves again here by at by specifying
our variable path and to have multiple
instances of this project class we
actually allowed ourselves to have
multiple sprite sheets so because
because the sprites will be across
several sprite sheets we also need to
define which sprite sheet the sprite is
actually inside of and we do that simply
by going private sprite sheet shape
we'll just call sheet all right and
we'll define all this in a minute now
the most important part of the sprite
class is the constructor so we'll type
public sprite now this is going to take
a few parameters first of all the size
of that particular sprite that we're
defining so we need to set the size
remember we've created this variable we
haven't set it to anything yet when we
actually create a new sprite object we
need to set a size to it we also need to
set x and y which I'll talk about in a
minute and we also need to set which
shape it is actually inside of so which
which sprite sheet contains our sprite
so first of all we've got this error and
that's right the reason we've got zero
is because they haven't actually set
size equal to anything so if we see you
know the blank field size may not have
been initialized the first thing we need
to do is actually set the size so we'll
go ahead and set the size equal to size
and that error should go away and what
what is this doing here get out
it is being legit there we go
so we've set the size equal to whatever
we put in our parameters here the other
thing we need to do is actually set the
X&Y now how's it going to work first of
all it's only pretty simple actually now
yesterday you might remember we actually
had a grid and each each grid each like
cell in that grid is a different sprite
so what happens is x and y is actually
going to be the coordinates of our
sprite now because the size of our
sprite is 16 and in other words I'll
probably keep it like that but again
we'd only be 2000 so I'll probably use
this size arm because the size is 16 we
need to set this dot x equal to x times
sighs all right so quick note about this
because this might be a bit difficult to
understand so again we are setting this
sprite instances x value x-coordinate of
where it's located on that sprite sheet
when we actually call it we want to be
like all right it's the fifth sprite
across and the second sprite down for
example right so the coordinates would
be 5 2 obviously in pixels that will be
5 times 16 for the x coordinate and the
y coordinate would be 2 times 16 because
we're trying to find 5 times 2 of sorry
5 by 2 that's where it's located this
will be a lot easier to understand or
not what I actually demonstrated in a
future episode but um basically what
this is doing is actually setting the
location of our target sprite in our
spreadsheet and again what it's going to
do the same thing for y next up we need
to again load this sheet into here so
we'll call this dot shape equals shape
and finally we actually need to load a
sprite and we'll do that by creating a
new method private method private void
load and again this is going to be the
same thing as this over here we loaded
that image in and we actually set the
pixel array to be that here we're going
to do a similar set a similar thing
we've already loaded the sprite sheet
image so all we need to do here is
actually access this sprite sheets
pixels and find the right
right so for that we need weed two for
loops on nested for loop um two for
loops and one of them is going to be Y
right so for in y equals 0 Y is less
than the size of our sprites actually
this will be the because 1 + y + + right
and then the same thing for X so x
equals 0 X is less than size X plus plus
so this will this will go go through all
of our pixels in our sprites now what we
need to do here is type pixels x + y
times size equals sheet dot pixels so
Alps pride cheats pixels now and this is
actually going to target where is going
to be so first of all actually we forgot
one thing sorry about that but pixels we
haven't actually set pixels equal to
anything so once we have our size we can
basically go ahead and say that pixels
equals new int size times size all right
and again we could use this size we
could use that size does really matter
so this is creating a picture this is
creating a new pixel array that's
actually the size of our sprite um so
essentially what that is is because
remember our pixel size ours or our
sprite size roughly now is about 16
we've sort of agreed to keep our sprite
16 the reason I'm just actually not
defining it as 16 is because we could
change that in the future or we could
have surprise set of multiple sizes
which is why I don't want to really keep
it redundant as as I said earlier but
what we do want to do here is actually
set that pixel array to be whatever
number of pixels our sprite contains so
in other words if we have a sprite that
is 16 by 16
it contains 16 times 16 pixels right and
we've done this before we've done we've
done it in the screen class for for the
map size and the screen size as well and
to contain every pixel on our national
screen so over here we've defined these
pixels to be the size of our sprite so
what we need to do now is actually cycle
through each one of those pixels and set
them equal to the appropriate sprite in
our sprite sheet so
what we're going to do here is actually
navigate to start off at that at that
actual point in into in the spritesheet
image so we need to type sorry X plus
this dot X because again this dot X
again is going to equal the appropriate
horizontal coordinate plus y plus this
sort Y and then times the actual size of
the sprite sheet so sheet dot size I
believe
KDOT size with matter private one let's
go back my shape
yeah we did make it private so let's
make it public and let's go over here
papa
oops all right so again I'm going to go
over this code right now so that you
guys understand it what this is doing
basically an overview of what this is
doing is its setting its basically
extracting a single sprite out of our
sprite sheet and is doing that by
setting this sprites pixels all the
pixels contained in this single is in
the singular sprite is setting them and
this is again scanning through every
pixel in that pixel object in that pixel
image it's setting them equal to a
specific pixel in the sprite sheet so
it's doing that by again accessing every
single pixel it's accessing the actual
sprite it's after it's accessing the
entire sprite sheet and then out of that
is extracting the appropriate pixel the
episode of the appropriate sprite and
it's doing that again by going by
finding the x coordinate which is just
simply this we should probably should
have done this dot X plus X again it
doesn't actually matter it might be
easier to read we're going to the
appropriate coordinate so you're going
this is probably a lot easier to
understand if I actually show you guys
an example of it I didn't really want to
though because we'll be we'll be looking
at demonstrating this earlier later when
we actually go to our game but if we if
we go to the x coordinate so say we want
to load um I don't know we've got we've
got a sprite in this cell and we want to
load it what we need to do is actually
go this dot X so we're going to this top
X is going to be like - let's just say
we input 2 into here it's going to go 2
times 16 so it's going to go all the way
that's 16 that's 1 that's 2 it's going
to go all the way over here right and
it's going to start at this let me just
sort of different color
by other colors window colors it's going
to start right over here all right is
found that x-coordinate now it's going
to go over here and do the same thing as
you can see this dot y plus y so it's
going to go down all the way here and
it's going to find this coordinate and
from here because it's going to keep
keep setting those pixels as long as the
y is less than size it's actually going
to scan all the way down here and all
the way over here thus encapsulating
this entire sprite and setting it equal
to pixels and that's how that works so I
hope you understood that it'll be much
easier I promise you when we actually
get on to demonstrating this and
actually applying this into our game but
yeah that's that's the end of this
episode guys tomorrow will probably take
a look at actually creating individual
sprites and loading them and seeing how
they work but until then guys if you
enjoyed this episode please hit the like
button and I'll see you guys tomorrow
with a brand new episode later guys
[Music]